Sequels are a big business in Hollywood, and
every studio loves a franchise.
Still, sometimes a movie just can't pass that
initial bar of quality that gets a sequel
greenlit in the first place.
Filmmakers might have grand plans for a franchise,
only to have them thwarted before they can
get started because of lousy reviews and low
box office receipts.
Here are some planned sequels that were completely
abandoned.
Superman Returns Again
Bryan Singer's Superman sequel from 2006 was
kind of a bad idea from the start.
It followed up the events of Superman II,
ignored Superman III and IV, and two of its
major plot points revolved around Superman
super-stalking his former girlfriend, Lois
Lane, as well as a revelation that her son
was their secret love child.
Worst of all, the movie didn't really give
Superman very much to do in terms of actually
fighting bad guys, which, y'know, is one of
the things Superman does best.
Warner Bros. pulled the plug on the possibility
of another Singer-helmed sequel, which screenwriter
Michael Dougherty says might've introduced
Brainiac and more Kryptonians to the screen.
"Identify."
"Try asking nice."
"Kryptonian…"
Batman Triumphant
George Clooney's first outing as the Caped
Crusader in 1997's Batman and Robin was not
supposed to be his last.
In fact, Warner Bros. was gearing up to bring
back Clooney and co-stars Chris O'Donnell
and Alicia Silverstone for a sequel titled
Batman Triumphant, which would've been directed
by Joel Schumacher.
However, Batman and Robin was a critical joke,
summoning more laughs than its campy script
ever intended.
Audiences who'd flocked to watch Val Kilmer
in the batsuit just two years before simply
didn't show up to see what Uma Thurman's Poison
Ivy and Arnold Schwarzenegger's Mr. Freeze
would be adding to the villainous fold this
go-round.
Spoiler alert: They didn't miss much — except
for a few terrible puns.
"What killed the dinosaurs?
The ice age!"
"My name is Freeze.
Learn it well for it's the chilling sound
of your doom."
Good times.
If Batman Triumphant had happened as planned,
it reportedly would've relied on the Scarecrow
and Harley Quinn as the Joker's daughter to
play the bad guys.
And they would've been joined by fear-gas
induced appearances from the Joker, Penguin,
Catwoman, Two-Face, and The Riddler in an
effort to get Bruce Wayne committed to Arkham
Asylum.
Dredd 2
This is probably the most tragic entry on
the list, since the first Dredd, starring
Karl Urban, is a legitimately amazing movie.
Unfortunately, it seems that the stink of
Sylvester Stallone's 1995 Judge Dredd adaptation
was too strong for moviegoers to ignore, and
Dredd failed to find an audience during its
theatrical run.
It's a cult hit, though, so there's still
an outside chance Dredd 2 could happen before
we all get old and die.
In fact, in early 2017, producer Adi Shankar
vowed to make some sort of follow-up happen
— even if it's animated.
He told Collider, "I'm gonna make it happen
at some point.
It may not be live-action, but it's going
to happen at some point.
There will be more Judge Dredd at some point."
Fantastic Four 3
The first cinematic outing from 20th Century
Fox's adaptation of Marvel's first family
wasn't great — but it did well enough to
spawn a sequel, 2007's Rise of the Silver
Surfer.
This one was actually a bit better, featuring
a version of Galactus and the Power Cosmic.
But it still wasn't good enough by a long
shot.
The franchise ground to a screeching halt
after it underperformed at the box office,
and as star Chris Evans later told MTV, no
one from the cast ever even got a call from
Fox about coming back for more.
Just goes to show you that signing a three-picture
deal doesn't mean as much as you might hope.
"Oh my God, come on!"
Green Lantern 2
The original 2011 Ryan Reynolds vehicle was
supposed to kickstart a whole DC superhero
franchise to rival Marvel's ever-expanding
cinematic universe.
DC's corporate parent, Warner Bros., bet big
on Green Lantern, spending a whopping $200
million on the movie — and it only barely
turned a profit.
Between the film's cliffhangers and its efforts
to build a big world for Green Lantern to
play in, the movie was considered a failure,
and all plans for a sequel were scrapped.
Now Green Lantern's set to be rebooted to
fit in with the DC Extended Universe…presumably,
at least the studio hopes, for the final time.
The Mortal Instruments: City of Ashes
By all estimations, the adaptation of Cassandra
Clare's Young Adult sensation series The Mortal
Instruments seemed like it'd be the next big
hit in the vein of Twilight and The Hunger
Games.
It had all the essential ingredients, including
a huge book-loving fanbase that clung to every
moment of the production phase and cast members
who engaged in an offscreen romance to mirror
their screen counterparts.
So, naturally, 2013's The Mortal Instruments:
City of Bones was expected to launch an entire
franchise that would've capitalized on the
craze surrounding its sister series.
The script for City of Ashes had already been
drawn up, and the actors and crew already
had a production schedule in place before
the results of the first film's release came
through — and put the brakes on everything.
It wasn't the early critical blasts that stymied
the sequel — don't forget, scathing reviewers
stung the Twilight Saga, too.
It was the fact that the much-hyped film grossly
disappointed at the box office, making just
half of its production budget back in domestic
sales, and, according to Cassandra Clare herself,
the sequel to Ashes would've been "unrecognizable"
to the book series faithful, thus weakening
audience interest even further.
Ultimately, despite some early signs that
the second Mortal Instruments pic might be
retooled and eventually made, the project
was abandoned, and the series was instead
relegated to the small screen by way of Freeform's
Shadowhunters.
So, it wasn't a total wash.
Twins 2: Triplets
Twins was something of a high-concept comedy
that revolves entirely around a single sight
gag: muscle-laden Austrian superman Arnold
Schwarzenegger and teeny tiny Brooklynite
Danny DeVito play long-lost twins.
The 1988 hit, directed by Ghostbusters mastermind
Ivan Reitman, was a breezy romp in which the
two stars hung out and goofed off under the
auspices of their characters getting to know
each other.
"Who are you?"
"I'm Vincent's brudda."
"We're twins."
And because Twins was such a hit, rumors hit
almost immediately after its release that
a sequel was coming.
In 1989, a representative for Reitman said
that the director was considering making a
movie called...wait for it...Triplets.
The top candidate to play the third long-lost
multiple didn't look anything like the others,
which was essential of course, and was the
hottest comedy star of the moment: Roseanne
Barr.
That movie never got made of course, but in
2012, there was renewed talk of Triplets,
without Barr, but with Eddie Murphy.
But considering how many years have passed
with no more news on that front, Triplets
is probably not gonna happen.
"No, don't start diss!"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!